Ça va être la dit Monsieur
Dorais. Vous avez été
responsable des grands parcs.
Pourquoi ça n'a pas été fait?
- Il y a un programme de 18
millions de réparations de
toilettes, de ponts, de
passerelles, de santé et d'accès
au stationnement. Ça peut être
fait d'ouvrir deux ou trois
toilettes. Justes ouvrir le
chalet, c'est une vingtaine de
millions de dollars. Il faudrait
faire au complet parce que c'est
un bâtiment patrimonial. Tous
les grands parcs de Montréal ont
besoin d'argent. Il y a 21
grands parcs. Les passerelles
l'île Bizard ont été fermée
pendant trois ou quatre ans. Les
marques de la visitation, les
rives devaient être protégées.
Il manque d'argent par rapport
au nombre de parcs et la volonté
d'une extension des grands parcs
et parce qu'on veut passer de 6
% de la protection du territoire
à 10 % de la protection du
territoire. Sous Montréal, on a
beaucoup acheté de terrain.
- On annonce, Mme Plante, on va
le voir à l'écran, un parc de
l'Ouest encore plus grand, mais
si on n'est pas capable de
s'occuper des parc existant, ça
sert à quoi d'annoncer... on vot
le plan pour l'Ouest et on va le
voir pour l'Est. Ça sera quoi
d'annoncer ça si on n'est pas
capable d'aimer ce qu'on a?
- C'est une urgence des proches
âgés les territoires. Il faut
augmenter le nombre des
territoires, d'espaces verts et
une concurrence contre des
entrepreneurs qui veulent
développer. On n'a pas le choix
d'être à la table au moment où
ça se passait faire
l'acquisition au moment où elle
doit être faite. C'est vrai que
ça gruge du budget qui ne peut
pas être mis dans l'exploitation
des parquets, la protection des
parcs existants. On ne peut pas
gagner sur les : il faut le
faire, il faut protéger plus de
territoires. Il n'y a pas
d'assez d'argent. Montréal a 21
grands parcs. Il faudrait, pour
avoir des parquets de qualité
partout sur le territoire,
tripler les budgets des grands
parcs.
- C'est quoi tripler les
budgets?
- Il faudra mettre au moins 200
millions. Un grand parking comme
Angrignon, ça prend au moins 150
millions.
- J'ai loué des pédalos il y a
40 ans au parc.
On disait : il y a un projet de
chalet. Faire un chalet avec des
toilettes, c'est pas 20 millions
quand même.
- Ces 22 6 millions de dollars.
Il faut le voir. C'est un chalet
en béton qui a été fait dans les
années 60. On peut pas les raser
du jour au lendemain. Le
rééquiper de l'intérieur, la
plomberie, l'électricité,
enlever l'amiante, refaire les
axes qui sont différents des
accès de l'ancien temps, c'est
20 millions de dollars pour
faire juste ça.
- Je voyais dans ma
documentation qu'il y a eu 15
projets annoncés ou en tout cas
sur la table à dessin pour les
parc à Grignon et à chaque fois
c'est tombé à l'eau. Vous dites
: il manque d'argent.
- Oui et on pourrait bien mettre
l'argent sur le parquet. Notre
tour s'en vient et on va mettre
l'argent. Oui, mais en termes
d'achalandage, il faut garder
tous les parquets. Il y a des
parquets qui ont cinq fois
l'achalandage de ce parquet. Le
parc Lafontaine, le théâtre de
verdure est fermé depuis cinq
ans parce qu'il n'était plus
utilisable.
- C'est incroyable. Vous allez à
Chicago, à Paris, à New York,
c'est une aberration pour ces
gens qui viennent visiter
Montréal que nos parcs ne soient
pas mieux entretenus, qu'il n'y
a pas de café. Tu amènes un
français au parc Angrignon,
il n'y a rien.
- Il pourrait y avoir une
ouverture d'un autre chalet, il
y en avait un petit soleil Smash
qui est un ancien kiosque. Ça
pourrait être fait.
Pour faire des parcs à la
hauteur des villes que vous
citez, c'est des centaines de
millions de dollars que ça prend
parce qu'il faut protéger les
rives, changer la forêt, refaire
les canalisations et les
drainages, les flashs
électriques pour avoir des
lampadaires, acheter des
lampadaires. C'est beaucoup
d'argent. On peut baisser un peu
et tourner les coins, mais c'est
beaucoup d'argent quand même. Je
souhaite que cet argent soit mis
sur la table.
- Vous dites : ça dépend de
l'achalandage. Les parcs en
général à Montréal, il y a eu un
accroissement de l'achalandage
de 70 % à cause de la pandémie.
Les gens veulent sortir. Ce sont
des richesses extraordinaires.
- Vous êtes un excellent avocat
pour les grands parcs. Vous
devez continuer à faire ça.
- Je mettrai des gardiens de
parc en plus.
- La ville veut acheter des
terrains pour faire des
logements sociaux, investir dans
les transports en commun, c'est
une bataille pour avoir les
millions. Je pense que les
grands par caisse, c'est un
investissement.
- Ce qui se demande où est Anie
Samson, je ne sais pas ce qu'il
arrivait. On a un problème
technique. Normalement, on
aurait dû faire un panel
politique. Je vais vous poser la
question sur un sondage léger
qui a été donné à TVA entre
autres, à LCN cet après-midi.
Ce tableau montre que Mme Plante
a rejoint M. Coderre. Ça va être
serré, Luc Ferrandez.
- Extrêmement serré et j'ai vu
que la satisfaction pour
Monsieur Coderre a baissé de 10
% depuis son retour, son sa
décision de courir pour la
mairie à aujourd'hui. Ils
n'étaient pas gagnants dans les
derniers mois. Je pense qu'il va
se rétablir. On va lui souhaiter
de se rétablir et d'avoir une
course chaude jusqu'à la fin.
Je pense que le vote pour
Desjardins va s'effondrer. Toute
la question, c'est de savoir où
ce vote va aller. Je pense qu'il
va aller chez Monsieur Coderre.
- Pourquoi il s'effondrerait? Là
il monte.
- Il a démontré qu'il était
pratiquement un imposteur en
termes de politique municipale.
Il veut enlever les statuts
bilingues de la ville de
Montréal. Il a fait des
déclarations en disant : tout
l'argent dégénéré à Montréal
doit rester à Montréal.
Ça n'a aucun bon sens de faire
une déclaration comme ça quand
tu cours à la mairie. Ça veut
dire que tu comprends pas la
base du système démocratique,
légal, financier et
gouver